all right welcome back to what's it
Wednesday episode 2 you made it a whole
week this is as some of you guessed many
of you guessed this is a bobcat so good
work it's a little bit too big actually
it's about 2 times the size of a house
cat skull unless you have a really
really big big house cat
their bones are extremely hard compared
to house cats as well at chintamani
Wildlife Center which is the place where
I volunteer we do wildlife
rehabilitation we got a bobcat in a
while ago and he had broken his I
believe it was his shoulder blade in
collarbone and we had to drill into the
shoulder blade to put in pins and
whatnot and we had standard bone drills
that you use on a normal cat and we
broke like four of them they are
incredibly tough little animals and they
are extremely vicious way way more
vicious than you would expect
Bobcats they're awesome little animals
they're super cute and sweet when
they're babies and they turn into little
demons as soon as they start hitting
puberty so a lot of people try and keep
them as pets bad idea super bad idea
don't do it Bobcat skull so
congratulations to all of you who
guessed that correctly now for our
second guest this is not an actual skull
it would be illegal for me to own this
well I mean I suppose I could get
permits to own one of these so this is a
bone clones replica and an extremely
well done replica as well not like not a
hundred percent sold on the beak here
that painted on beak but other than that
this is the most beautiful replica that
I've think I've ever seen of a bird
skull
it's absolutely detailed like look at
that you can see all the texture he'd
even had a original specimen that they
had it must have been like a tumor or
something going on here you can even see
the the actual character from the
original individual they took this from
notice that's not on the other side so
this thing yeah
beautiful let's look at that there's the
little bone clones stamp so that you
don't get arrested for owning an illegal
skull by the way most actually all birds
of prey if this is a bird of prey I'm
giving away too many hints all birds of
prey are protected by federal law in the
United States you can't own any bits of
pieces of them
a little tiny little tiny opening
opening up into a fairly large brain
case I mean most of it's like space for
the eyes you can see there you know it's
just empty there but birds do have
fairly large brains compared to like a
reptile er
something
it's neat these the this space here is
also found on t-rex and you know
dinosaurs a lot of people on a t-rex
they'll think that that's where the AI
goes because it's actually back a little
bit further there are three holes on the
t-rex there's a hole right here there's
a hole for the AI then there's this hole
then there's the nose hole on a on a
theropod dinosaur
and this is a bird obviously I think not
one's going to be confused about that so
I might as well just tell you this is a
type of bird and birds of course evolved
from dinosaurs and so they have these
similar bone structures that beak it's a
nice little cup shape the bottom fits
into the top here just like just perfect
there you have it let me know what you
think this is in the comments and if
you're right you will be right on the
Internet
congratulations